-Our next guest...
[ Screaming ]
Wow.
...is a five-time
Grammy-nominated artist
[ Drumroll ]
and a global pop music icon
that you know from BTS.
His debut --
[ Screaming continues ]
His debut solo album,
"Face," is out now!
Please welcome
Jimin!
[ Screaming continues ]
-♪ We'll go face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go
face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go
face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go
face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go
face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go
face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go face-to-face ♪
♪ We'll go
face-to-face ♪
[ Drumroll ]
-Wow!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Screaming ]
Wow!
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
-Whoa!
[ Screaming ]
-Welcome -- yeah -- Jimin.
Jimin, welcome back to the show.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-The last time you were here
was a big deal.
It was the first time you were
nominated for a Grammy.
And I think, the first time
you were on our show,
you were like,
"I really want a Grammy."
Now, you're five-time nominated
-Oh, wow.
-for a Grammy. Come on.
[ Screaming and applause ]
-Congratulations!
-Thank you.
Thank you, Jimmy.
We could be nominated thanks
to fans' great support.
I appreciate them.
[ Screaming and applause ]
-Yeah.
I will say you have
the greatest fans.
-Yeah.
-You had -- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Screaming ]
More --
I'm sure more Grammy nominations
on the way, by the way.
This is fantastic.
[ Screaming and applause ]
And thank you for always
being supportive of us
because we have similar names,
[ Laughter ]
so, I'm very,
very excited, yeah.
But I know the rest of the guys
are concentrating
on their solo projects,
currently,
but are you in contact?
Do you talk every day?
-We keep in touch.
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
With who, in particular?
-With J-Hope.
[ Screaming and applause ]
With Suga.
Everyone.
-I want to talk about your new
album, but I also --
[ Screaming and applause ]
Yeah, "Face."
But I want to know more
of your story, okay?
Was making music
[ Awws and screaming ]
always the plan for --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Awws ]
-Look at this guy.
-That's a kid.
-Yeah.
-This is me.
[ Screaming and whistling ]
-Yeah.
Was making music always the plan
for this little man
and also, when did you realize
how talented you were?
-When I was in middle school.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering ]
I found interesting dance
and since then, it was always
my dream to perform onstage.
-Yeah, always.
And could you imagine
how big it's gotten?
[ Laughter ]
No, no. It's the biggest thing
in the world.
Jimin, you have a lot
of nicknames, by the way.
Is it Mochi?
-[All] Mochi!
-Chim Chim?
-Chim Chim.
-Little Prince.
[ Laughter ]
-Little Prince?
-Yeah?
Yes.
-Dooly.
-Dooly?
-Dooly, yeah.
That's one of your --
Do you have a favorite nickname?
-My favorite nickname is
Jimin Fallon.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Screaming ]
[ Rimshot ]
-I didn't make you say that.
I did not make him say that.
That's so good.
Thank you.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Over the summer,
you and the rest of the guys
got to go to the White House
[ Cheering and applause ]
and...
meet with President Joe Biden.
That is such a big deal.
How important, how big,
was this for you?
-Oh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-People go nuts for you.
They freak out
when they see you. I was --
[ Screaming ]
-[ Laughs ]
-He's right here!
I know!
[ Screaming continues ]
I freak out.
I'm freaking out, too.
I'm freaking out right now.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is there anyone that you --
that you have met
that you get starstruck
when you met?
-Oh, first...
Jimmy Fallon?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Maybe you're so funny and sweet.
[ Awws ]
-Thank you.
-And --
-Who for real, though?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And Halsey.
-Halsey?
-Halsey.
-Oh, really?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-She has --
She has a big heart
and she has the talent
that make anyone starstruck.
-Yeah.
[ Awws ]
-All our members love her.
-Yeah, everyone loves Halsey.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We love Halsey, too.
Let's talk about your new album,
"Face."
This is --
[ Screaming and applause ]
It is officially out now!
It is out!
-Oh, no!
-It's out!
[ Screaming ]
I know, Can you talk about the
inspiration for this album
and what it represents to you?
-Absolutely.
Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And when you have a new song,
do you play it
for the rest of BTS?
And do you listen
to anyone else?
-Uh-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, a little bit?
A little bit.
-Maybe.
-I have a question for you.
This is an honest question.
I didn't prepare this,
but I have this problem
and I want to know
if you can help me.
I go to a concert
and I feel like I'm too old
[ Laughter ]
to go to a show.
I just don't know.
Well, here, help me out.
I have a problem.
I go to a concert, I don't know
how to dance at a concert
and I was wondering if you could
maybe teach me a dance
that could be --
I could do anywhere.
-Oh, sure.
-You could?
-Okay.
Stand up.
Come on.
[ Screaming and applause ]
There.
Okay.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Let's go.
-Okay.
[ Music plays ]
-Come closer.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Touch my hand.
And look at the camera.
That's it.
-That's it?
Wow!
-Let's go.
-I do that at a concert?
-Let's do it.
-Alright. Ready?
♪♪
[ Screaming and applause ]
[ Voices overlapping ]
Jimin, everybody!
"Face" is out now!
[ Screaming and applause ]
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
-Thank you.
-I love that.
That's so good.
Just do it like that.
♪♪